[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Sirin schönen guten Abend
neben mir ist wieder Katja später unter
anderem mit Neuigkeiten vom DFB so
sieht's aus schönen guten Abend dann
schauen wir jetzt auf die Thema an
diesem Mittwoch
Vorwürfe in diskretionen offener Streit
die öffentlichen Auseinandersetzungen in
der Koalition müssen aufhören fordert
SPD-Chef klingen bleiben
Eskalation bei reichsbürgerratien ein
Polizist wird bei einem Schusswechsel
verletzt
und vom Überfluss zur Mangelware
Wasserknappheit wird für immer mehr
Länder ein Problem
[Musik]
die harmoniebilder von Schloss Meseberg
können aktuell nicht über die Tatsache
hinweg täuschen dass die
Regierungspartner derzeit vieles sind
aber harmonisch gehört eher nicht dazu
zu unterschiedlich die Vorstellungen bei
den gemeinsamen Gesetzesvorhaben grünen
Vizekanzler Harbeck fand dafür deutliche
Worte in einem Interview vor dem
Koalitionsausschuss am Sonntag ist der
Koalitionsfrieden jedenfalls ziemlich
gestört Andrea Maurer
2.600 Kilometer vom politischen Berlin
entfernt in Ankara appelliert heute der
SPD-Chef an die Koalition Politik zu
machen statt zu streiten dafür müssen
wir jetzt in einen anderen Arbeitsmodus
kommen es kann nicht sein dass wir jeden
Tag öffentlichen Streit erleben dass wir
Vorwürfe Erleben der jüngste Vorwurf
kommt von Vizekanzler Harbeck der
gestern in den Tagesthemen zur Kritik an
seinen Plänen zum Austausch von Gas und
Ölheizungen befragt wird hier ist der
Gesetzentwurf an die Bild-Zeitung und
ich muss also unterstellen bewusst
geliebt worden um den Vertrauen in der
Regierung zu schaden und insofern sind
die Gespräche wie finanzieren wir es
genau eine abgestimmte ressortvorlage
eine Einigung möglicherweise mit den
Koalitionspartnern zerstört worden gegen
wen sein Vorwurf gerichtet ist sagt habe
ich nicht die SPD unterstellt ihm heute
stark unter Druck zu stehen die
spd-bauministerin mit der Habeck am
Gesetzentwurf arbeitet will seine
Empörung nicht verstehen ist ein Vorgang
der wenn man in der Politik ist
irgendwie jede dritte Woche vorkommt ich
habe schon vor vielen Jahren beschlossen
mich über sowas nicht mehr aufzuregen
die Stimmung ist gereizt vor allem
zwischen FDP und grün die Grünen werfen
der fdp-blockade Haltung vor die FDP den
Grünen technologieoffenheit zu
verhindern und Debatten nicht führen zu
wollen ich glaube es ist richtig dass
wir vorankommen müssen bei den Themen in
die wir uns vorgenommen haben und dazu
gehört ja auch das Thema Klimawandel
gleichzeitig wenn ein Gesetzentwurf in
die Öffentlichkeit kommt und er noch
nicht abgestimmt ist dann muss man ihn
diskutieren können der Austausch von Öl
und Gasheizung nur eins von vielen
Streitthemen in dieser Koalition am
Sonntag Tag der Koalitionsausschuss er
soll die Knoten durchschlagen
gehen wir nach Berlin zu Theo call Theo
nun rumorts schon länger in der
Koalition warum bricht der Streit jetzt
auf offener Bühne aus also ich glaube
aktuell ausgelöst wurde es sicher durch
die heftige Prügel die Robert Habeck für
seine durchgestochenen Pläne bekommen
hat zum verboten neuer Öl und Gasheizung
der Kanzler hält sich zwar öffentlich
zurück aber in vielen Stellen wird ja
deutlich dass die SPD sich da nicht auf
die Seite der Grünen schlägt und es gibt
mindestens zwei weitere wichtige Gründe
für den Groll die FDP hat mit den
verlorenen Landtagswahlen im Nacken ganz
klar das Thema Auto für sich als
Gewinner Thema definiert und zwar sowohl
den Kampf für den weiteren Einsatz von
verbrennermotoren Stichwort e-fuels als
auch den beschleunigten Autobahnausbau
und in gewisser Weise geht die
Ampelkoalition ja erst jetzt in ihr
erstes richtiges regierungsjahr denn das
Vergangene war ja war ja geprägt durch
die unmittelbare Krisenbewältigung der
zweiten Welt und deshalb wird auch erst
jetzt die ganze Spannweite der
inhaltlichen Unterschiede tatsächlich
entsprechend reibungsintensiv dürften
dann auch am Sonntag beim
Koalitionsausschuss möglicher Einigungen
werden das wird spannend danke für die
Einschätzung nach Berlin Theo
bei deutschlandweiten Razzien gegen
Reichsbürger wurde heute eine sea K
Beamter in Baden-Württemberg
angeschossen und verletzt wie ernst man
diese Szene nehmen muss hatte zuletzt
eine Razzia im Dezember gezeigt damals
wurde bekannt dass eine Gruppe aus
diesem Milieu offenbar einen gewaltsamen
Sturz der Regierung plante die heutige
Razzia stand in direktem Zusammenhang
mit der dezember-aktion mehr jetzt von
Nina kuscheln
gleich mehrere Schüsse fallen hier heute
morgen in der Wohnung in Reutlingen bei
der Razzia im reichsbürgermilieu
eskaliert die Situation als die Polizei
die Wohnung stürmt hat der 46-Jährige
Markus l schon eine großkalibrige Waffe
auf die Beamten gerichtet es kommt zum
Schusswechsel der Mann trifft einen
Polizisten in den Unterarm und gibt
danach auf
daran sieht man aber wie gefährlich
diese reichsbürgerszene ist sie ist
offensichtlich bewaffnet und wir werden
jetzt prüfen müssen ob der Täter auch im
Besitz legaler Waffenbesitzkarten war
nach zdf-informationen hatte der Mann
als Sportschütze legalen Zugang zu
Waffen und auch zu Sprengstoff insgesamt
werden bei der großrats ja heute in acht
Bundesländern und der Schweiz 20 Objekte
durchsucht bei fünf Personen besteht der
Verdacht der Unterstützung einer
terroristischen Vereinigung 14 weitere
Wohnungen werden ebenfalls durchsucht
auch der Mann in Reutlingen war ins
Visier der Ermittler geraten weil er die
verfassungsmäßige Ordnung Deutschlands
ablehnen soll
bereits Anfang Dezember hatte es eine
große Razzia gegen die sogenannten
Reichsbürger gegeben 25 von ihnen sitzen
seitdem in U-Haft unter ihnen auch der
Frankfurter Geschäftsmann Heinrich der
13 Prinz Royce mutmaßlicher Kopf des
Netzwerks das soll einen gewaltsamen
politischen Umsturz geplant haben der
Schütze von heute sitzt bereits in
Untersuchungshaft gegen ihn wird nun
ermittelt wegen mehrfachen versuchten
Mordes
holen wir unsere Rechtsexpertin
sarattacke in Berlin dazu Sarah wo
stehen denn in diesem Fall jetzt die
Ermittlungen der Bundesanwaltschaft
die Ermittlungen des
Generalbundesanwalts sind in vollem
Gange und werden vermutlich auch noch
eine ganze Weile dauern denn die große
Herausforderung für die Ermittler ist
dass sie es hier mit einem mutmaßlichen
Reichsbürger Terror-Netzwerk zu tun
haben das extrem heterogen ist heißt
konkret die mutmaßlichen Terroristen
Leben in ganz Deutschland verteilt in
verschiedenen Bundesländern und sind
auch sehr verschieden altersmäßig aber
auch wenn man sich die Berufe der
mutmaßlichen Terroristen anschaut das
sollen darunter Soldaten sein Polizisten
Ärzte Richter Köche Musiker das zeigt
wie verschieden sie sind das einzige was
sie eint ist Ihr Ziel sie wollen die
demokratische Grundordnung in der wir
leben stürzen sie wollen den Systeme
Umsturz und was sie gefährlich macht ist
das einige unter ihnen sein sollen die
legalen Zugang zu Waffen und auch zu
Sprengstoff haben sollen das heißt die
neuen Festnahmen und Durchsuchungen
heute werden wieder zu neuen
Erkenntnissen führen und es kann gut
sein dass in einigen Wochen und Monaten
ist auch wieder weitere neue
Durchsuchungen und Festnahmen geben wird
denn der Generalbundesanwalt ist aktuell
soweit dieses Netzwerk komplett
auszuleuchten Dankeschön nach Berlin für
diese Hintergründe Sarah Attacke Razzia
bei den reichsbürgern da stellen sich
wieder viele Fragen wie tickt die Szene
wer hat sich da radikalisiert und wie
hoch ist die Gewaltbereitschaft der
Mitglieder Infos dazu auf unserer ZDF
heute bzw in der ZDF heute
die Aussichten für die Konjunktur in
Deutschland werden besser in einem
milden Winter habe sich die Wirtschaft
widerstandsfähig gezeigt sagen die
sogenannten Wirtschaftsweisen und
erwarten in ihrer Konjunkturprognose für
dieses Jahr ein minimales Wachstum von
0,2 %. vor einem halben Jahr war der
Expertenrat noch von einer leichten
Rezession ausgegangen für 20-24 liegt
die Wachstumsprognose jetzt bei 1,3%
. Warnstreiks im öffentlichen Dienst
haben heute wieder den Verkehr in vielen
Städten lahmgelegt an der Haltestelle um
die Ecke aber auch im Hamburger Hafen
der für große Schiffe gesperrt wurde
weil die Lotsen streiken 10 tausende
Beschäftigte machten bei Kundgebungen
noch mal Druck auf die Arbeitgeber auch
morgen soll es in unterschiedlichen
Bereichen Warnstreiks geben die nächste
Verhandlungsrunde steht dann ab
kommendem Montag an
mehr Tempo beim Ausbau der Windkraft in
Deutschland das will die Bundesregierung
und Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck hat
deshalb zum windkraftgipfel eingeladen
das Ziel hat die Regierung selbst
vorgegeben zwei Prozent der Landfläche
sollen bis 2032 für Windkraft
ausgewiesen werden dafür hat sie zuletzt
beschlossen Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren zu vereinfachen
und trotzdem nimmt der Ausbau nicht
wirklich Fahrt auf Andreas Huppert
berichtet
Strom aus Wind das Kernelement deutscher
Energiewende denn um alle
Klimaschutzziele zu erreichen muss die
Stromerzeugung so schnell wie möglich
grün werden doch der nötige Ausbau hängt
den Anforderungen hinterher deshalb hat
der Wirtschaftsminister zum windgipfel
geladen knapp zwei Stunden hinter
verschlossenen Türen eine
Standortbestimmung mit der Erkenntnis
Hauptprobleme bleiben die langsame
Genehmigungsverfahren wir sehen doch
nicht die genehmigungsgeschwindigkeit
die notwendig ist aber in den Gesprächen
mit den Ministerpräsidenten und den
zuständigen Energie Ministerinnen und
Ministern es ist eindeutig so dass sie
sagen ja wir wissen wir wollen und wir
ziehen wir ziehen jetzt an und ich denke
das werden wir auch bald in der Fläche
sehen die Windenergiebranche ist das
skeptisch sieht sich bei den
Genehmigungsverfahren immer noch
benachteiligt wir brauchen die gleiche
Bereitschaft wie man sie bei den
lng-terminals im Genehmigungsprozess für
fossile Energien gehabt hat jetzt auch
für erneuerbare Energien diese
Bereitschaft fehlt offensichtlich noch
ein weiteres Problem stoppt der
Windkraftausbau gehen Arbeitsplätze
hierzulande verloren Entwicklung und
Produktion wandern ins Ausland wie schon
bei der Photovoltaik hier kommen
mittlerweile 70% aller Module aus China
wir haben alleine in den Krisenjahren
2017 bis 2019 40.000 Beschäftigte
verloren wenn man alles zusammenrechnet
sogar knapp 60.000 insofern hat es
natürlich auch eine wesentliche
arbeitsmarktpolitische Komponente und so
bleibt nach dem ersten Wind Gipfel die
Erkenntnis Probleme erkannt Probleme
aber noch lange nicht behoben
der russische Krieg gegen die Ukraine
führt nicht nur zu unermesslichen
menschlichem Leid sondern auch zu
enormen materiellen Schäden die UNO die
Weltbank und andere Organisationen haben
ausgerechnet dass der Wiederaufbau der
Ukraine schon jetzt fast 400 Milliarden
Euro kosten würde und Tod und Zerstörung
gehen immer weiter bei russischen
Angriffen sind nach ukrainischen Angaben
insgesamt mindestens 14 Menschen getötet
worden eine Brüder berichtet
Ruhm der Ukraine um den Helden an diesem
Ort haben diese Worte eine ganz
besondere Bedeutung selensky bei bachmut
zum zweiten Mal schon ist der hier um
Ordner an die zu verteilen die an
vorderster Front kämpfen
ich habe heute die Ehre die besten
unserer Helden auszuzeichnen ich möchte
Ihnen danken die Hand drücken dafür dass
sie den Staat die Souveränität und den
Osten der Ukraine verteidigen
bachmut Symbol für den Wahnsinn dieses
Kriegs seit Monaten kämpfen Ukrainer und
Russen um jeden Zentimeter Gelände
gewinnen während die Zivilbevölkerung im
ganzen Land jederzeit mit russischen
Luftangriffen rechnen muss das hier hat
eine Überwachungskamera aufgezeichnet
eine russische Rakete trifft ein
Wohnhaus in saporisha südlich von Kiew
wird eine Schule mit Wohnheimen
getroffen mindestens vier Menschen
sterben
wir wissen die meisten Menschen sind
runter in den Keller gegangen wir haben
mehr als 200 aus dem Bunker evakuiert
aber einige sind oben geblieben Tod
Trauer Leid allgegenwärtig in der
Ukraine
ich bin Ihnen wirklich sehr dankbar
jedem und jeder passen Sie gut auf sich
auf alles Gute
als Geschenk bekommt selensky eine
ukrainische Flagge der Kampf um bachmut
soll das wohl heißen ist noch nicht
entschieden
ein klares Buster bekamen die Franzosen
heute von ihrem Präsidenten zu hören im
Fernsehinterview es bleibe bei der
Rentenreform er werde standhaft bleiben
macrons mit Spannung erwarteter Auftritt
dürfte die Gegner eine Anhebung des
Rentenalters wohl kaum beeindrucken sie
machten heute auch weiter Druck mit
Demos Blockaden und Streiks in weiten
Teilen des Landes Anna Arend aus Paris
die Wut auf macron scheint grenzenlos
seine Gegner lassen eine
präsidentenattrappe auf den
bahnhofvorplatz von Nizza knallen einige
rufen zur Revolution auf kurz bevor der
echte Präsident der sich bislang eher
bedeckt gehalten hatte die Reform im
TV-Interview verteidigt
glauben Sie diese Reform bereitet mir
Freude nein denken Sie ich hätte es
nicht wie meine Vorgänger halten und das
Rentenproblem ignorieren können ja
vielleicht aber in Wahrheit bereue ich
nur eines dass es uns nicht gelungen ist
die Notwendigkeit dieser Reform zu
vermitteln
von der er keineswegs abrückt um ein
Defizit in der Rentenkasse zu verhindern
werden künftig zwei Stellschrauben
angezogen das mindesteintrittsalter
steigt von 62 auf 64 Jahre volle Bezüge
bekommt aber nur wer 43 Jahre lang
eingezahlt hat das beides erfüllt sein
muss wird als ungerecht empfunden
besonders bei jenen die wenig verdienen
jene deren Stimmen die Rechtspopulistin
Marine Le Pen einfangen will
die Demonstrationen sowie die Streiks
sind rechtmäßig verfassungskonform und
das sage ich mit Überzeugung legitim sie
sind Teil eines friedlichen und
demokratischen Widerstands gegen die
Arroganz und die Gewalt der Regierung
nur noch weiter anheizen angesichts
solcher Bilder scheint es schwer
vorstellbar wie der politische Dialog
wieder in Gang kommen soll Frankreich
verharrt in unruhigen Zeiten
Wasser und erst recht sauberes Wasser
wird weltweit immer knapper erstmals
seit Jahrzehnten will jetzt eine
UN-Konferenz Lösungen für die damit
verbundenen Probleme erarbeiten derzeit
fehlt jedem vierten Menschen ausreichend
Zugang zu Trinkwasser und alle zwei
Minuten stirbt ein Kind an Krankheiten
durch verschmutztes Wasser dabei wächst
der weltweite Bedarf immer weiter an
während sich gleichzeitig dürren auch in
Regionen ausbreiten die früher als
ungefährdet gehalten auch in Europa auch
in Deutschland sind Maßnahmen gefragt
Christina igelzeder die Granetalsperre
gut gefüllt wie lange nicht mehr etwa
13% des Trinkwassers in Niedersachsen
kommt aus den Harzer Talsperren der
Regen der vergangenen Wochen hat vorerst
für Entspannung gesorgt wir haben
Wasseranfall hier in Nordharz den wir
gerne speichern würden den wir aktuell
aufgrund unseres begrenzten
Speichervolumens nicht mehr speichern
können das heißt uns geht jetzt schon
Wasser verloren dass wir eventuell in
lange drücken Perioden brauchen können
die Reservoirs offenbar nicht groß genug
solche Bilder von den Harzer Talsperren
wir aus dem letzten Jahr gilt es zu
vermeiden
Trinkwasservorräte die durch die
trockenen Sommermonate schrumpfen es
geht hier darum dass wir das Wasser aus
dem Winter zu viel haben Stärke in den
Sommer bringen gleichzeitig muss man
aber auch sagen man sollte jetzt nicht
den Eindruck erwecken dass wir dafür
sorgen dass zukünftig unbegrenzt Wasser
zur Verfügung steht der Teil der
wasserstrategie ist auch dass man dafür
sorgt dass Wasser nicht verschwendet
wird
nachhaltiges Wassermanagement für
Deutschland immer wichtiger in
Niedersachsen werden Moore gerade
renaturiert und bereits seit mehreren
Jahren wird Wasser aus den Flüssen
genutzt um die Grundwasserstände
aufzufüllen Felder und Wälder besser zu
versorgen wir sind in Deutschland in der
sehr guten Situationen dass wir uns an
die die wasserhaushaltsveränderung
anpassen können und das unterscheidet
uns ja ganz zentral zum Beispiel vom
Mittelmeerraum denn dort sind auch die
Winter immer trockener um den Reichen
Winter Regen hierzulande besser zu
speichern sollen die Mauern der
granatalsperre um etwa 10 Meter erhöht
werden die Anpassung an die
Klimaveränderungen sie ist möglich aber
sie wird teuer
so jetzt zum Sport und zu Katja der DFB
hat entschieden dass die Kapitänsbinde
wieder Schwarz-Rot-Gold ist ist das der
richtige Weg sagen wir mal so ist
zumindest einer der wieder für
Diskussionen sorgt aber der DFB sagt es
soll ab sofort wieder nur um Fußball
gehen ein frommer Wunsch wahrscheinlich
erster Einsatz der Binde Samstag im
Testspiel gegen Peru
Rudi Völlers Vorschlag wird umgesetzt
die umstrittene one love-binde
Vergangenheit und damit aus DFB Sicht
hoffentlich auch die Diskussion darüber
künftig trägt der Kapitän der
Nationalmannschaft wieder schwarz rot
gold ganz wichtig dass wir auch aus
dieser Situation lernen dass der Fokus
bei uns völlig auf dem fußballerischen
liegt und damit unter anderem auch auf
der Frage nach dem Spielsystem von Hansi
fliegt Niklas Füllkrug einer der
Lichtblicke bei der WM bevorzugt zwei
nominelle Stürmer ich glaube dass wir da
auch viele Spieler haben hier bei der
Nationalmannschaft die das extrem gut
verkörpern die den Gegner schon in sehr
gefährliche Situation bringen können
möglicherweise schon am Samstag gegen
Peru
ja und gegen den FC Arsenal haben die
Fußballerinnen des FC Bayern München
gestern 1:0 im Champions League
Viertelfinale gewonnen Spielerin des
Spiels Lea Schiller sie sorgte per Kopf
für den Siegtreffer in der 39 Minute und
rettete zweimal stark auch bayernlinie
das Rückspiel dann in einer Woche in
London
ja nach knapp 17 Jahren als Profi
beendet Mesut Özil seine durchaus
erfolgreiche Karriere Weltmeister mit
Deutschland mehrfacher Pokalsieger in
Spanien und England zuletzt aber häufig
verletzt und auch umstritten die völlig
verpatzte WM 2018 bedeutete für den
brillianten Techniker einen tiefen
Einschnitt weniger weil dort
fußballerisch nichts klappte sondern
viel mehr weil er sich zuvor kräftig ins
Abseits gestellt hatte mit einem
Fototermin beim türkischen Präsidenten
Erdogan auch sein Abschied aus der
Nationalmannschaft mit
rassismusvorwürfen gegen den DFB Riss
tiefe Gräben auf und das nachdem der
ehemalige Schalker bei Real Madrid und
bei Arsenal London zu einem Weltstar
aufgestiegen war Krönung der Karriere
der WM gewinnt 2014 mit Deutschland
seine letzten Jahre bei Fenerbahce und
baschaki hier Istanbul nur noch mit
wenigen Highlights Zeit sich zu
verabschieden
mit jetzt 34 Jahren vielen Dank Katja
wir hätten jetzt noch die Lottozahlen
für sie und die gehen so 19 28 33 35 35
40 und die Superzahl lautet 3 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf lotto.zdf.de und auf
der ZDF Text Seite 557
das Wetter bringt Schauer Gewitter und
Sturm mehr dazu gleich von ostentherly
um 21 Uhr des heute-journal mit
Christian Siebers morgen um 19 Uhr hier
Barbara Hellweg passen Sie auf sich auf
und noch einen entspannten Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter auf dieser Karte
summiert sich der Regen auf der bis
Sonntag fällt und sie sehen die Farben
werden intensiver das blau wird
intensiver und hier in den westlichen
Mittelgebirgen gibt es durchaus bis zu
40 Liter auf den Quadratmeter blickt man
auf die alten Südseite kommt hier kaum
nennenswerter Regen an hier setzt sich
die Dürre weiter fort der Blick in die
Nacht von Südwesten kommt Regen auf
verlagert sich nach Nordosten hier erst
einmal trockene auch im Süden
Temperaturrückgang auf drei Grad an den
alten und 11 Grad ganz im Westen morgen
am Vormittag dann im Norden teils noch
mit Sturmböen dazu auch Regen im Süden
wird es allmählich Trockner die Sonne
zeigt sich schon zum Nachmittag ist es
dort häufiger sonnig und nach Norden hin
Schau und Gewitter können auch mal
kräftiger ausfallen bei höchsten
Temperaturen bis 21 Grad nach Südosten
hin und fünf Grad in Schleswig-Holstein
die nächsten Tage ruppig geht es weiter
mit Sturm Richtung Nordsee dazu Schauer
und Gewitter 10 bis 18 Grad Samstag dann
fast überall mal Sturmböen und das bei 8
bis 14 Grad Sonntag Kühler schöner Abend